to the latest on the war in ukraine this
morning people are asking what president
biden intended to express when he said
that russia's president cannot remain in
power the president ad-libbed that
remark during a speech in poland on
saturday where he met with ukrainian
refugees mr biden and other officials
say he did not mean to call for regime
change in moscow his increasingly strong
rhetoric however has the global
community concerned about what may come
next in the war in ukraine weijiajang is
following all this for us and she's at
the white house this morning rija good
morning
good morning the white house has been
extremely careful in crafting all of its
messages about the russian invasion even
before it happened deeply concerned
about potentially escalating the
situation but president biden has a
tendency to go off script which in this
case stirred up a diplomatic and
communications crisis that the world
continues to watch
one day after making this remarkable
comment about vladimir putin for god's
sake this man cannot remain power
president biden provided little clarity
when asked what he meant as he left
church on sunday evening were you
calling for regime change
earlier secretary of state anthony
blinken insisted the president was not
suggesting an immediate change to
russia's government quite simply
president putin cannot be empowered
to wage war or engage in aggression
against ukraine
or anyone else we do not have a strategy
of regime change in russia or anywhere
else for that matter the kremlin had a
different interpretation a spokesman
said it's not up to mr biden or
americans to decide who will remain in
power in russia adding only russians who
vote for their president can decide that
please mr president stay on script idaho
senator james risch the ranking
republican member of the senate foreign
relations committee called president
biden's comment a quote horrendous gaffe
anytime you say or even as he did
suggest
that the policy was regime change
it's going to cause a huge problem
critics worry it will empower putin at a
crucial time when peace talks are
already fragile and that the fiery
rhetoric overshadowed the president's
main mission of his visit to europe to
emphasize that western nations will
remain united against russia we have a
sacred obligation under article 5 to
defend each and every inch
of nato territory
for the full force of our collective
power
this week president biden will try to
shift some of the focus back to his
domestic agenda in fact later today he
is planning to reveal his new budget
proposal which includes a tax hike on
america's wealthiest people trying to
make sure they pay at least 20 percent
of all their income
all right we jang for us at the white
house thank you weja